après les échanges téléphoniques avec
ses homologues russe et ukrainien le
déplacement en personne emmanuel macron
se rend d'abord ce lundi à moscou puis
mardi à kiev avait comme ambition
d'avancer vers une désescalade dans le
dossier ukrainien des rencontres
bilatérales alors que washington a
haussé le ton ce week end indiquant
craindre une invasion à grande échelle
de l'ukraine les troupes d'élite
américaines ont atterri dimanche matin
en pologne non loin de la frontière
ukrainienne signe que washington prend
au sérieux la menace d'une invasion qui
est arrivé c'est à dire qu'ils seraient
là ce critère est une invasion de
l'ukraine avait son produit
auprès des alliés william durand serrée
sur les partenaires d'urgence
mais kiev relativise pour l'instant ce
risque le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne appelant à se méfier des
prévisions apocalyptiques et à trouver
une solution diplomatique avec moscou
avant sa rencontre avec vladimir poutine
le président français a indiqué dans les
colonnes du journal du dimanche que
l'objectif géopolitique de la russie
n'était pas l'ukraine mais de clarifier
les règles de cohabitation avec l'otan
et l'union européenne
la russie nie toute intention d'
invasion de son voisin ukrainien
pourtant elle amassé assez frontière
avec l'ukraine près de cent mille
soldats des mouvements militaires
inacceptable pour les occidentaux
de plus plusieurs mois moscou réclame la
garantie que l'ukraine n'intégrera
jamais l'otan une demande rejetée en
bloc par les alliés